Jeremy Hunt welcome to The Economist
asks hello so at the time that we're
sitting down with you here at The
Economist the latest polling shows you
inching ahead of your cabinet colleague
Michael Gove so in second place to Boris
Johnson who seems to be leading the
fields on MPs nominations only two of
you go forward to the membership for the
final runoff
why should mp's back you what makes you
different from Michael Gove or indeed
Boris Johnson well there are lots of
things that are very different about me
I'd be the first Prime Minister who's
been an entrepreneur by background for
example but the central issue that is
going to dominate this leadership
campaign is who is most likely to
deliver brexit and the European
Parliament elections and the local
election results have been a wake-up
call to the Conservative Party that we
will be obliterated in a general
election if we have not delivered what
we promised to do in the last general
election and we at the moment are in a
situation where we have some very bad
choices if we carry on as we're doing at
the moment Parliament will block a No
Deal brexit and the EU will block a
better deal that would perhaps get
through Parliament and so the question
the reason I think I will progress in
this campaign and get forward and and
hopefully win the campaign is because I
am saying to be well let's be honest
about the choices we actually face and
let's choose the person who can give us
some better choices some better options
options that we don't have at the moment
and as foreign secretary I've been
talking to European leaders for the last
year I've got a sense of the
complexities of the issues of the
Regis's in the European Union and I'm
not going to say this is easy but I will
say that if we go in with a very hard
line approach we will just get a
hard-line response we'll get to October
the 31st and nothing will have changed
and then the only likely way to resolve
this would be a general election and I
think that would put Jeremy Corbyn in
Downing Street and be absolutely
catastrophic for the Conservative Party
that's the Labour leader you
opposition party made opposition so
you've called it political suicide to
allow a No Deal brexit to happen
subsequently you seemed to suggest that
you would negotiate as if no deal were
possible can you just absolutely clarify
for us what is your position on No Deal
yes um I will I didn't say no deal was
political suicide I said having a
general election would be political
suicide and if your only way to deal
with a parliament that is blocking No
Deal was to have a general election that
would be political suicide I've always
believed that we should keep no deal on
the table because I still think that I
still do and I will say it might happen
if you keep it on the table well it
might be taken away by Parliament and
that's what's already happened this year
that's why we have to be honest about
the parliamentary arithmetic that we
face and I've always said that if the
only way to deliver brexit was leaving
without a deal and that really was the
only way to do it then I would do that
but because I think in the end the
Democratic risk of not delivering brexit
is higher than the economic risk of No
Deal but I would do it with a heavy
heart because of the risks to our
businesses the risks to the Union and I
would not do it if there was a chance of
a good deal that could get through
Parliament and what i want to be is the
prime minister who gets that good deal
on the table negotiates it i'm a
businessman by background i negotiated
the junior doctors contract which is one
the longest contract negotiations we
have ever had a very bitter industrial
dispute but i also did the BBC licence
fee in less than 24 hours in 2010 so i
i've got experience of negotiations but
not gonna do this one in 24 hours I
think deal is as bad as the economist
has been pretty clear all along and
we've done very deep dives on it for a
number of perspectives that we think it
is pretty catastrophic for the UK
economy not very good for Europe either
do you share the depth of feeling that
The Economist has I agree No Deal would
not be good for the British economy it
would have a significant impact on our
economic growth
it would also be bad for the EU the
extent to which it will be bad really
depends on the context if you had if you
like a hostile No Deal where you know we
were threatening not to pay our bills
and there was an atmosphere of animosity
then the economic consequences could be
really very damaging indeed if you had a
more constructive atmosphere with both
sides having tried very hard but not
able to reach a conclusion then the
consequences could be mitigated and you
can't know until you are actually in the
situation which of those two it's going
to be but how high is the probability of
a No Deal in percentage terms roughly
well I can't say that I mean my view is
that Parliament has already shown that
it won't allow No Deal
it's already passed a bill over the
government's head taking control of the
order paper in Parliament completely
unprecedented
in order to require the well you know I
personally think that Parliament should
leave these matters to the executive but
we are a parliamentary democracy we have
to follow the law and if Parliament
makes a law even the Prime Minister has
to follow it so I think it is very
unrealistic to think the Parliament
wouldn't do that again
we just interviewed Rory Stewart who's a
contender perhaps even more of a soft
brexit contender this race fought for
this show also he was very clear that he
wouldn't serve under Boris Johnson other
any candidates that you would wouldn't
serve under in this race no I think
there are outstanding candidates and I
think that people should do their duty
but I have to say that I also hope they
would all be willing to serve under me
because I think what we have to do as a
party is come together this has been a
very damaging period if we don't deliver
brexit we are finished as a party and if
we don't unite we won't deliver brexit
why are you better candidate than
Michael Gove all candidates have their
strengths and weaknesses I'd rather talk
about my own strengths and and other
people's weaknesses and my crazy self in
my case I wouldn't just be the first
Prime Minister who's been an
entrepreneur by background I'd be the
first Prime Minister's run the NHS the
fifth largest organization in the world
I'd be the first Prime Minister who's
won a marginal seat in a quarter of a
century these are things that are going
to be helpful facing the challenges we
face is it fair to change leaders in
this select your donkey Derby that we're
in with a very small selector at a time
of absolute national crisis without the
country being consulted well this is
what happens in a parliamentary
democracy because political parties form
governments and they elect their leaders
according to their own rules and and
that's how it is but in the end what
will not change with the leadership
election is the parliamentary arithmetic
the MPs that people have voted to send
to Parliament and that's why a new
leader has to recognize the reality of
that arithmetic that it is likely to
block No Deal and that therefore the
only way through the conundrum is to
find a better deal and the question is
who is the candidate who is most likely
to get that better deal we've looked at
other ways out of the sound posture and
in depth at a second referendum in some
form I think you have consistently
opposed that what's your key argument
for not simply going back to where we
started this started with going to the
people and asking them whether they
wanted to remain or leave the EU what
would be wrong with going back well let
me put it this way let's say you had a
second referendum and the result was
exactly reversed and 52 percent voted
remain and 48 percent voted leave if
that happened would that settle the
issue
you'd have 48 percent of the country
that had voted twice to leave they would
be absolutely furious and they would say
well you've had a second referendum can
we have a third one can we have a fourth
one and they would think it was
profoundly undemocratic so I don't think
a second referendum souls anything which
away it's out in any circumstances I
will not vote for a second referendum
and let me say this the way unite you
unite the car party sorry the way you
unite the country is by delivering
brexit but finding a form of brexit that
works for the 48% Hoover
to remain as well and many of the people
who voted to remain in the EU had
perfectly legitimate concerns about
brexit and one of the things we need to
do is to reassure them that for example
did you remain yes well we can go into
those reasons as well but one of the
things we need to do is to reassure them
that we're not going to change the
fundamental character of the country
we're not going to pull up the
drawbridge put down the shutters say
foreigners not welcomed do you regret
voting remain in the referendum well I
voted remain because I was worried about
the economic risks of leaving and the
economy has proved to be much more
robust since the brexit decision then we
thought if you remember the Treasury was
putting out forecasts saying we would
have property price crashes and you know
an immediate recession no but they
promised that from the moment you
decided to leave these things would
happen and they haven't so knowing what
you know now would you voted leave well
I if there was a referendum again I
would vote to leave because I think this
is the only way we will resolve this
issue so you've been foreign secretary
for a year now at the heart of the
brexit negotiations they haven't
succeeded how did we get here that we
need to learn from and how much of it is
the fault of treasom a well look I don't
think this is the time in last week as
leader the Conservative Party to be
pointing any fingers as you say we
weren't successful the end and I think
we're all very disappointed that that
didn't happen what can we learn well one
of the reasons that the EU stopped
negotiating with us and making
concessions was because they didn't
believe that the British government and
resume could deliver a majority in
parliament so I think as we go back into
this process again and we need to
assemble a negotiating team that has on
that team the DUP the ERG which is a
wing of the Conservative Party Scottish
and Welsh conservatives
so that the EU know that any proposal
made by the British government can be
delivered through the British Parliament
thinks one of the first rules of
negotiation people
to think they can bank your promises and
if we do that and if we approach the
negotiations in a in a constructive tone
I believe there is a deal there because
it is very much in the --use interests
to come to a deal as it is in our
interests but if we go in with the wrong
approach they will just sit and wait for
Parliament to block No Deal will end up
having a huge debate over an extension
and I think for people on the
conservative side the thing to remember
is that Labour is beginning to look like
a more attractive option for the
European Union because it supports the
customs union and it looks like it's
going to support a second referendum so
I think we need to be very careful not
to find ourselves tipped into a general
election which would do untold damage
Donald Trump has just been visiting
you've spent some time with him how did
you find him he was a bully --nt on good
form I think he enjoyed the state visit
I think he was very moved by the D Day
commemorations and you know he is a
larger-than-life politician and you know
you can love or loathe Donald Trump well
I have a lot of respect for the
president I don't agree with him on
everything I disagree with him on
climate change for example on the Iran
nuclear deal but what I notice about
America is that they have a GDP growth
rate that is double ours and I think
that at the point of brexit one of the
things that we need to consider very
carefully is what we do to turbocharge
the British economy and why is that just
think what a remain supporting newspaper
like The Economist
what would make you in ten years time
through gritted teeth write an editorial
entitled Britain's surprising brexit
success well the answer is you might
just write that editorial if our growth
rate has been higher than European Union
countries over that 10 years you'd
definitely write the opposite if it had
been lower so I think the name of the
game if we want to make a success of
brexit is to turbocharge the economy
that's where I've
said I think we should cut corporation
tax to twelve and a half percent which
is Irish levels as a sin as a strong
signal that on the point of brexit we
are determined to be the most
pro-business Pro Enterprise high tech
greenest economy in Europe what do you
say to those who say actually many of
his values are not those that should be
emulated or celebrated and who have
wished for a moment perhaps of those at
the very top of politics like yourself
to send it a clearer message about that
to this president well look at the
reason that President Trump came to
Portsmouth yesterday to commemorate the
d-day landings exactly 75 years ago that
was a moment of profound importance
because we were celebrating an alliance
between Britain and America that far
transcends happening now but you've got
to let me answer the question that
alliance transcends any individual
politicians so when you look at the
world today and you see a much more
aggressive Russia you see a more
autonomous China you have to ask
yourself is that alliance between the UK
and the USA or the two countries that
created the international order that has
made the world richer more peaceful
record life expectancy record numbers of
diseases answering the question you've
got to say tough is that alliance still
relevant and I think it is and in the
end I think that America is the leader
of the free world and we need to work
alongside America and as I say with
President Trump there are things we
disagree with but on things like the
economy on the is the way he is boosted
growth in the American economy there's
lots we can learn from but underneath
all of that is the protection the
defense the sustaining of a world order
that I think has been uniquely
successful President Trump this week
promised the UK a phenomenal trade deal
but one where everything is on the table
and
includes NHS procurement which you know
a lot about as a former health secretary
how realistic is that it does seem to be
something of a requirement from the
American side however strongly many
Brits feel that the NHS should be in
their hands and not those of American
companies in any meaningful form well I
spend a bit of time explaining to
president Rob about the NHS when he was
over here you mean he didn't understand
it first well he's the American
president and expect him to understand
everything about our health care system
here and he actually terrified an
interview with Piers Morgan that he was
not seeking to put NHS procurement on
the table when we talk about health care
products if you talk about medicines
medical devices these things are freely
traded around the world anyway they can
be part of any trade deal but NHS
procurement the ownership of the NHS
that's never going to be for sale under
any prime minister I'd like to turn
finally to something else and that's the
huawei case and particularly what the
implications would be for security
obviously the American administration
there has taken a very tough line with
the company
you've managed to calm some concerns
about that I think about their equipment
being used as a backdoor to espionage
but the first of 5g networks in the UK
has already been launched and Huawei
hardware is in it are we looking the
stable door after the horses build it
well we have to make a decision as to
the extent that we use far away we
haven't made that final decision and the
considerations are firstly what you've
just said which is the you know
espionage issue can you be sure that
that equipment isn't being used as a
back door and we have some of the best
technical experts in the world we look
at their advice very very carefully but
the second issue is a strategic one
which is you know China has It's Made in
China 2025 program where they're
explicit that they want to get an 80%
global market share of telecoms
equipment technology and we have to ask
ourselves 5g is going to be something
that dominates our lives
in a way that 3g and 4g never did
because it will control our driverless
cars it will control the heating in our
house and that really a reason why the
more and you've had this debate in
cabinets we know because it kept being
leaked a lot of people just feel
therefore you should just be much firmer
in shutting Huawei out well I'd say this
is not about China this is about whether
we want to become technologically
dependent on any third country when we
know that these technologies are going
to be so important to our future do you
feel that China is an enemy to Western
democracies and to the United Kingdom
was thinks and how did you characterise
China you do a lot about it your wife is
Chinese you've traveled there
extensively what is our relationship
with China absolutely not an enemy we
should welcome the rise of China when
China catches up with the United States
we should remember which some people say
could happen as soon as 10 years time we
should remember their GDP per head will
still only be a quarter of the USA's GDP
per head and you know why shouldn't they
want to raise their people out of
grinding poverty but China has to make
choices about the kind of country it
wants to be and the way that it uses its
power and we don't share their values
when it comes to human rights and that's
been talking to the major figure in the
Armed Forces
who talked about it being relentless was
his word are you sort of soft-pedaling a
bit on on the threat not at all and I
think the league first of all I think we
do need to find a way to live alongside
China because they are a powerful and
successful country but the closeness of
our relationship to China will be
determined by choices that China itself
makes did you win that argument with the
American delegation over this week I
think you could Leo economists argued in
favor of a compromise on Huawei not so
perhaps different from where you are in
this argument Americans it seems to come
in all guns blazing saying they really
would like Britain to drop Huawei did
anything move this week well we listen
very carefully to what the Americans say
but in the end we will
decision based on the British national
interest they're our closest ally we
have a fantastically important military
and intelligence relationship with them
we don't always agree with them but we
will certainly list them very carefully
what are the chances that next time we
see you you're the leader of the
Conservative Party and indeed the Prime
Minister what all I says you get
slightly longer odds on me than some of
the other candidates so I'm the one if
you want to make money
there's the entrepreneur Jeremy Hunt
thank you very much thank you